[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i dated a stripper
she brought it out of here she was a
filthy animal she brought that she would
make me spend my we could do a gig with
400 bucks yeah she'd make take me to the
400 miles and she dumped me
then we get into a fight and i get
thrown out into the street with 18 after
i just bought groceries at a house i'm
like and i would take like the prime
beef with me like walk down the street
[Laughter]
leave the clothes you're
the last time her and i thought was in
la
and she was spraying me with mace
and i was throwing uh like a prime
ribata yeah fought on
the street next to vista in between
santa monica boulevard and sunset in
1990 with mace i didn't know she would
make sure you shoot me with me and i was
blocking it with the meat
and swinging at it with the [ __ ] meat
at each other and after that we're like
listen man
once you shoot mace at your boyfriend he
hits you
time to really break up yeah and we
broke up and today we're great friends i
love stand up more than anything so i
don't mind you know grinding
as as hard as i like tomorrow i'm gonna
stir tomorrow i'm gonna take a flight
at midnight to new york i land at nine
in the morning i'll do two podcasts and
then i hop on a flight to russia
you know what i mean like a lot of
people just won't do that a lot of
people will be like i i'm gonna be tired
so i'll just subtract tired
i'll subtract a lot of [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up
like friend like i haven't seen a lot of
my friends kids it [ __ ] sucks
but like there's certain things you got
to sacrifice if you want to be great at
things you didn't get put on this planet
to be look at kids anyway
that's for epstein you could be the
funniest guy in the world but if you're
not selling the ticket it's a game
they're not going to talk boom as simple
as that and i didn't know that either
when i got here in 98 i'm like no i'm
killing up at the store because we think
it's about killing it
it's not about killing that killing [ __ ]
is for you and me it's not about it's
not for them that's a personal thing
that you want to do on your own that's
it i want to go give them everything the
[ __ ] i got
but there's people i see on tv and i was
watching some disney channel my daughter
and i had to go to the ice house that
night and it was some [ __ ] challenge
of the network kids or something and one
of the hosts was the next comic
that i knew from years ago and i watched
that show and i felt so bad for him
he's like isn't that great yeah that's
what i'm going to be a universal
i'd rather be at the funny bone in
columbus [ __ ] slinging dicks
up on stage rocking it you know what i'm
saying
you know this weekend if you're a comic
and you're on labor day i i i applaud
you yeah if you took the week but ain't
nobody gonna come especially on the east
coast yeah yeah they're all grilling
outside [ __ ] waiting for hurricane
yeah donny osborne
you know uh there's certain weeks that
we don't have the time you know uh
there's no reason for me to work
father's day mother's day easter i got a
family also if you don't have a life you
don't have comedy you don't have comedy
yes so yeah like you could tell the
[ __ ] that don't have a life
because the [ __ ] got no soul
it's like
i don't know like i imagine even having
a daughter that changes your comedy he's
like you got more soul your soul
expanded listen the first 10 years of
comedy
i had nothing i have no responsibility
and the comedy reflects it right it's
like
i had a [ __ ] car that had no bumper
no insurance yeah no brakes yeah but the
love of comedy yeah overrode everything
sure it usually does it overrides
everything yeah you know
but the comedy itself needs life man
like
even like getting in a relationship
getting out of relationship like you
could tell when like a comic has just
experienced something because there's
something for them to [ __ ] chew on
and then you can tell the guys who like
you know they just don't have anything
so they can write really clever jokes
but there's nothing behind it there's no
passion like i would rather hear you
rant about a horrible uber ride
than hear some guy's clever uber joke
and he could have more punch lines in
his joke but i know you felt that way
about the uber ride i know you really
felt these [ __ ] things about the guy
in the front seat and he didn't move the
passenger seat back so you couldn't fit
like whatever the [ __ ] that is he was
talking on the phone in arabic and i
kept thinking he was talking with me you
were going those ubers you're like what
yeah what the [ __ ] you talking to yeah
you haven't shut the [ __ ] up since the
episode who the [ __ ] are you talking who
the [ __ ] an hour are you on the phone
who wants to talk to somebody when
they're on the phone for an hour it's
like black people see black people
they're going to get pizza and they're
on the phone with somebody still in the
bluetooth is this i'm the type of
[ __ ] that's the pizza
dog let me get two slices
pepperoni yeah i told that [ __ ] yeah
let me get uh let me get a great you
know whatever the [ __ ] they're eating
then they have a conversation and that
person is still on the [ __ ] phone i'm
like hey conduct your business okay i
gotta get off the phone
listen to every [ __ ] word you're
saying
get the [ __ ] off the phone it's like you
said there's really no excuses you go
out there
whatever
you want to be a drummer or whatever
but you have to
stick
with it see that's the problem yeah
people do something for nine months oh
it didn't work out who gives a [ __ ]
stick with it do it for 18 months
do it for the wall man now i'm getting
50 hits i'm like okay
then do it for another nine months man
you were right i'm getting 90. it was
crazy because people want to go from
zero to a million yeah
and it's like oh they want to go viral
they try to make crazy like this
this video will go viral unless you got
a dog who lights his [ __ ] on fire
you got a chance of going viral like
chlamydia that's the only chance you got
it going viral i was disappointed for
two minutes i didn't hear back from
netflix yeah
like that's how disappointed i was great
company they gave me a great opportunity
i don't know how to
a friend of mine had an expression
growing up
and he used to always say sometimes it's
better to want than to have
when i
when i got the call for the degenerate
special i just agreed to it i didn't
think it out right and it really pissed
me off that i would be so careless
at the age of 55 right i've been
careless all my life and i've thought
out every [ __ ] move you know
when i heard that it was being shot in a
pool room
you know there was just so many things
that weren't who i am right but i didn't
give a [ __ ] right i had my mouth open
like one of those michael jackson
accusers
i was going
to australia and i was staying next to
him you know that's why i sympathize
with those michael jackson yeah accusers
because because he wanted it one minute
you weren't excited yeah you'll suck a
dick on the way that's why harvey
weinstein in my world yeah he might go
to great if he might go to jail if you
if he raped somebody i want harvey
weinstein to go to jail yeah but unless
you lived in l.a
you won't send harvey weinstein to go to
jail yeah because people will there's a
woman out there that's 26 that's
gorgeous
and she will get on the hands and knees
yes and suck a 60 year old [ __ ] that
tastes like that
tastes like that
i mean you know i i mean i smell my dick
sometimes it smells just
[ __ ] god-awful at 56. i can't imagine
what woman would you know suck a dick to
get put in the movie it will be done out
here oh an oscar winner it's a shortcut
it's a shortcut yeah it's a shortcut
people love shortcuts and i don't even
blame them no you cannot blame them
because they don't care about the art
they just want to be famous and so
you're just going to do whatever makes
you famous and what happened to me was
when they called and said netflix
netflix everybody's like netflix you're
going to be so lucky yeah it wasn't
until i got there that i said
i didn't think this all right yeah
i didn't think this out right and then i
went on stage and had a bag of dicks
yeah and i was even more pissed off yeah
because it's like if i'm gonna eat one
he's gonna be on my own
yeah yeah yeah if there's one thing that
i maybe helped out with comedy is like
ushered in the expectations of the
viewer the viewer is fine with a comedy
club now that's where all of us put our
clips and i think that's where you know
i i may be put out there in the world
that that's where comedy should be seen
so now that it's okay to do in a comedy
club not a [ __ ] carnegie hall i can't
stand that [ __ ] just put the [ __ ]
cameras up
let them go don't tell anybody did they
do one of the greatest specials with
danger fields oh cuz i mean didn't they
do one of the greatest specials at
dangerfield many several things reveal
several and it's like and that club
sucks
today bro there's nobody in there holy
[ __ ] nobody is so comfortable they're
like sagged back in the seats but that's
such nice people where do you work you
want to know what weinstein's dick
smells like
go to dangerfield i love you take a
whiff
we're very lucky we love all the [ __ ]
you were talking about you i would love
to do a special and see a chandelier
fall
and the guy do 10 minutes on the
chandelier falling you know that's what
i live for yeah but the networks you
know oh it's got to be polished
you know and i've seen people nitpick
specials over years
and that's for no reason the bottom line
is is it funny
or not is it real man well the lighting
wasn't given
shut the [ __ ] up it doesn't matter dude
yeah prove that all wrong
you forgiven all those [ __ ]
that said well you need to spend 250 000
and get a crane and 10 midgets to dance
and a long opening i even loved your
opening you're talking to some black guy
he's selling your nickel bag you get up
and you go do your thing
again you went right out there
attacked the [ __ ] korean yeah and i'm
watching all this payback this guy
doesn't give a [ __ ] that's why he's
doing what he's doing and the audience
he has is reading this yeah that he's
going against whatever comedy central
things whatever netflix thinks whatever
hbo thought of comedy whatever true tv
things i don't know what the [ __ ]
they're thinking you know it's like hey
the advice land shoot yourselves yeah
it's like eight networks to just there's
like eight networks that you would say
you think about it yeah
you really think about how many networks
in your heart you would really want to
go on it's tough man in your heart that
you would go i really want to go over
there but if you're going to put me
after who the [ __ ] wants to go on comedy
central there's nothing there
that's not the next they're going out
and they go deeper
and deeper into the hole and with every
show like really that's your answer oh
[ __ ]
there's eight guys doing tremendous
podcasts and this is the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you picked for late it's [ __ ]
mind-boggling it's mind-boggling [ __ ]
crab feast is doing better than most
your [ __ ] shows yeah
what's his name
that's a ryan man sickles are [ __ ]
savage yeah yeah put him on a [ __ ]
show at 11 o'clock and let's have three
[ __ ] normal guests but the people
that they keep putting on and shoving
down your [ __ ] throat and you're
supposed to like them one day you're
like i don't even what do i like this
[ __ ] person for they're doing
everything for me to like
i like people that do things for me not
to like like you you're not support
because i don't care if you like me or
not he's not uncommon
he's better he's on his own [ __ ] time
his own universe put the money up what
do you want for a million people that
[ __ ] with me heavy to see your brand
what does that mean i mean because once
we start doing that
once we start going direct to the
advertiser
[ __ ]
it's over it's like we don't need
anybody we literally need nobody we need
hbo and netflix et cetera because
they're the ones that have the money but
once we get the money direct and
nobody's chopping it
why would you go anywhere else
why would you go anywhere else
does it make any sense yeah
i think i mean that was part of the
reason why i dropped the same day as
chappelle like i released it the same
day of chapel because i was i was like
that's a 20 million dollar special
and i wanted to put out especially it
was zero million dollars and i wanted
you to watch some back-to-back
and i wanted you to tell me i want to
true i want you to truly watch them
back-to-back and then
just be like what did i laugh
20 million dollars more
that's brilliant [ __ ] i just i wanted to
sell coke in high school
i tried to sell weed when i was in spain
man but i wasn't good at it so i was
like if i do this
i'm gonna do this the right way i asked
a thousand questions i got a job yeah as
like a door guy at a club yes a thousand
questions yeah
i knew the other day somebody wrote uh
you know restocked your shirts you could
make more money and i'm like
if i wanted to make money yeah i would
have got into selling cocaine yeah
yeah when i got into this at the
beginning
from day one
[Music]
[Music]
ain't no right way just the wrong way i
know
[Music]